vilnius has one of europe's best
preserved old towns but we've arranged
to meet rolando's vietkowskas at this
sports hall
the man who ran vilnius's european
cultural capital program in 2009 is now
director of the newly founded lithuanian
film center
the hall has served as a film studio for
several years now rolandis wants to
establish lithuania as a center for
filmmaking and he's already managed to
attract many international productions
to the city
we are good in some
setting constructions we we
production
and so on so so people when they come
they really get the complex of services
the two of us set off for a stroll
through the city's historical center
vilnius has more than 50 churches
saint catherine's has a special spot in
rolandes's heart because he was an
adviser to the culture ministry when it
was restoring the church
like many other houses of worship it was
left to crumble apart during the soviet
era
today the baroque style building hosts
concerts
another new feature in the old town is
the alley of authors hundreds of writers
have been immortalized here including
nobel prize winners such as germany's
goons grass
we stroll past the presidential palace
on july the first lithuania began its
six-month presidency of the european
union council
rolandes hopes that will translate into
positive promotion vilnius has often
been overshadowed by the latvian capital
riga the largest city in the baltics but
it has a lot to offer
the bell tower of st john's church for
example an elevator takes us up 45
meters to the platform and our
lithuanian guy loves the view out over
one of europe's largest old town centres
you live here now since more than 20
years
i guess you've seen the city change a
lot right absolutely actually it's the
idea of
build up
a new
city a
new architecture on the right side of
river which crosses the city was i think
good idea just really to give a
possibility for city to develop to
create a kind of a new center
after we view the old district rolander
shows me vilnius's modern side the
contemporary art center is the largest
in the baltics
it stages numerous exhibitions with
artists from around the world
it also has a very popular cinema we
watch our report from 2009
back then vilnius was proud to be a
european cultural capital
then the economic crisis struck and the
arts budget for the year was halved
the original director quit and verlander
stepped into the breach to salvage what
he could he managed to stage a range of
festivals and shows despite the tight
budget
the aim was to broaden the spectrum of
cultural events and facilities in
vilnius
so four years after
being the the cultural capital
would you say it helped the city to to
improve i think a lot of initiatives
which were born
preparing to become a culture capital
during the capital year
uh
survived this
this crisis times while the
the creative competition
but those initiatives aren't all that's
new and vilnius rolandis also shows us
an outlet of an extremely successful
fashion label julia janus
it now also sells designer household
objects like these candles the perfect
souvenir for the next euromax contest
we conclude our tour in bistro 18.
rolandis's favorite restaurant in the
old city
he hopes more places like it will open
because attractive shops and restaurants
help to draw more tourists after all he
says vilnius is far too beautiful to be
ignored